Miyazaki just did a bunch of interviews, and
we learned a lot of really significant things.
For example..see this weapon art?
Turns out, it's not specific to this weapon..instead,
you can mix and match weapon arts to multiple
weapons.
See this pot boy?
You might be able to capture enemies like
this, and summon them as spirit helpers that
fight alongside you.
Bosses can supposedly be tackled in any order..
The story is fascinating..and
..multiplayer is meant to be more convenient
than ever before.
Elden Ring news has only just begun..so please
subscribe, and keep up with it all.
For the purposes of this video though, I've
split the information into four categories.
Gameplay, the Open World, Multiplayer, and
Story.
First up, Gameplay.
Specifically, combat.
Elden Ring will see the return of the stamina
bar - though Miyazaki notes that he feels
it has less influence on the player overall.
If I had to speculate, perhaps it feels more
akin to Bloodborne, where stamina stops you
spamming actions up to a certain point, but
still allows for faster paced gameplay.
They've obviously learned a lot from working
on Sekiro..and like Sekiro, Elden Ring also
has an implementation of stealth.
You can crouch to sneak up on enemies, bypass
certain areas, or simply assess situations
while hiding in long grass.
Additionally, when night falls, your stealth
is enhanced..but your visibility is decreased,
and some scary enemies will only appear at
night, as well.
Elden Ring now also has a jump button, allowing
you to avoid sweeping attacks, and perform
jump attacks that differ based on the weapon
you wield.
Furthermore, fall damage has been greatly
reduced to encourage your vertical exploration.
And unlike any From game before it, Elden
Ring has horseback combat - though Miyazaki
stresses that most battles will still be done
on foot, except for certain fights where you
might need the extra mobility.
But the newest, most fascinating addition
to Elden Ring's gameplay..are "summonable
spirits".
As seen briefly in the trailer, these are
enemy-based spirits that fight alongside you..fulfilling
certain roles, like tanking for you, attacking
from range, or assisting you in melee.
They're able to be levelled up, and maybe
even customised.
Now, they can't be summoned everywhere..but
they are something you're supposed to consider
as a part of your build, similar to how you
pick a weapon.
And like weapons..who you choose to summon
will come down to personal taste.
Miyazaki himself says players might often
enjoy a certain enemy tagging along with them,
even if they're not of much use in combat.
Pot boy, I choose you!
It's funny..ever since I saw Father Owl summon
a bird that defends him, I thought this would
make a good addition to the game..and it's
crazy that it's actually a thing now.
In fact, you literally see a character summon
a bird here.
Spirits having specific roles and unique animations
is so, so much better than another human NPC
following you around, like in Dark souls.
Overall though, Elden Ring is probably closest
to Dark Souls in terms of gameplay and combat.
This is what I expected - but what I didn't
expect was how deep they're going with build
customisation.
Because in addition to magic, weapons, armour,
and spirit summons..you also have "skills".
So in Dark Souls, every weapon had a different
weapon art, special attacks that could be
activated with L2.
Sekiro also had combat arts, which you could
equip to your character, and perform by holding
L1 and pressing R1.
Now, in Elden Ring..we have "skills", which
are kind of a combination of Weapon Arts,
and Combat Arts.
There are around a hundred skills in total,
and they can be freely assigned to a large
variety of weapons.
So you see this jump back slash the character
is doing with this curved sword?
If you liked the skill, but not the weapon..you
could assign this skill to a different weapon.
If you're about to face a boss that would
be weak to a certain weapon art, perhaps you
can even apply that weapon art on the fly.
This is an insane amount of build variety,
pvp players are going to love this, and it
will help fill the open world with discoverable
abilities.
The open world is also filled with crafting
materials, which you can search for to create
the items you need most.
A lot of these, says Miyazaki, will be healing
items, which will be necessary since you might
be fighting for a longer time between checkpoints,
than in previous games.
Of course, experience in-game can also be
used to level up your character.
So between skills, spirit summons, weapons,
magic, armour, consumables and crafting materials..you'll
have a ton of tools at your disposal to take
on the world.
This will almost certainly affect the difficulty
of the game, specifically its skill floor.
Something like Sekiro, for example, has a
very high skill floor.
In order to progress, you literally have to
have the mechanical skill to overcome certain
fights- you can't rely on levelling up your
character, or using tools that the boss is
weak to.
Elden Ring, on the other hand, will offer
ways in-game to overcome difficulty..just
like Dark Souls did.
This isn't a bad thing - it just means that
if you're lacking a bit of mechanical skill,
difficulty can also be overcome with with
preparation, co-operation, and exploration.
While exploring the massive world, you'll
also have access to a World Map, which you
can consult to see where you are, where you've
been, and where you've yet to go.
This map will work in the open world, but
not in the smaller spaces of each map.
These "legacy" dungeons are more akin to what
we're used to in Dark Souls, and each open
world will have its own main dungeon, as well
as catacombs, camps, and fortresses interspersed
throughout the map.
There are six Open Worlds that we'll be exploring,
each the domain of "demigod" characters that
we'll discuss in another video.
These areas are called the "Lands Between",
and they're arranged in such a way that there
is a logical progression to them, though you
don't have to follow it.
In fact, you can skip more than half the game's
bosses if you want to.
In that sense, it sounds a lot like Breath
of the Wild, where the main path is quite
clear, but side paths are tempting to explore.
According to Miyazaki, none of these side
paths, or side quests will appear on your
map.
Instead, it's up to the player to mark these
things themselves manually, which I think
is fantastic for immersion.
A little later in the game, the player will
be able to access a hub area, where you can
branch out into the six main areas of the
Lands Between.
On top of this, fast travel is also present,
though From Software encourage users to enjoy
the exploration and uncover the map for themselves.
Like in all open world games, the more you
discover, the more powerful your character
becomes..and I'm sure the difficulty of a
From Software will be a great motivator for
exploration.
Another motivator for exploration are meetings
with plot characters, who add drama to the
journey, twists to the narrative, and influence
the endings.
According to Miyazaki, the NPCs you meet will
have a big impact on your worldview, and reveal
how they see the world.
In fact, he calls them "protagonists", and
says they're an "extremely important" part
of Elden Ring, which is certainly more than
he's said about NPCs in past games.
For all these NPC's however, there will be
no bustling towns, or villages, in Elden Ring.
This isn't their specialty, he says, so they've
chosen to focus on other things.
The usual story presentation methods through
item descriptions and dialogue are to be expected,
though the team says they're also leveraging
what they've learned from Sekiro and will
be better able to present the surface plot
through dialogue and cutscenes.
What is different this time, is how the story
of this game came to be written.
In the past, Miyazaki says, he would set a
game system and then write a story that matches
that - but this time, it was the opposite.
George Martin wrote the foundations of the
story - he came up with the mythos of the
world..including the Tarnished and the 6 demigods..and
THEN the team applied gameplay systems to
suit that.
They said that they expected to have to leave
out parts of the mythos to suit the game systems,
but that it ended up not being like that,
and that the collaboration was a very fruitful
one.
We actually already know quite a bit about
the lore of the game, and it's really helped
to contextualise a lot of the stuff in the
original trailer.
Please, stay tuned for that in my next video.
Speaking of collaboration, the developers
are aiming to make it easier to co-op.
Firstly, resources like humanity and embers
previously needed for co-op have been reduced,
or removed.
Secondly, special locations exist in the world
where players can leave their signs to see
who is currently available.
Lastly, once you're sharing a world, it seems
interface elements will be added to provide
information about other players in the world.
To enhance the connection you have to those
around you, "Groups" are being added to the
game.
Once you join a group, you'll be able to single
out the phantoms, bloodstains, and messages
from others in your group, allowing you to
connect on a more relatable level.
For example, I'll probably be able to set
the password "Vaati", and you guys will be
able to see and connect with what everyone
in our community is doing.
On top of this, the game will also have covenants,
which often add flavour to the multiplayer.
So this would be something like the Aldritch
Faithful from Dark Souls 3, for example, where
you role-play as a defender of Aldritch.
PvP is of course confirmed, even in the massive
open field, which is a nice surprise.
That said, Miyazaki says that you won't be
able to use your horse in the open field..which..confuses
me.
I can see how PvP might be awkward on horseback..but
I wonder how they're going to stop two fighting
so necessary?